hi I'm Tom Holland and I play Peter
Parker aka spider-man in the upcoming
movie spider-man far from home in
celebration of the movie and IGN's live
coverage of e3 I'm excited to share some
amazing art and footage highlighting the
new spider-man suits from the film enjoy
I need a suit you take care of the suit
I'll take care of the music
how's the food it's a little tight
around the old web-shooter in Parker
okay
got gifts Parker the world needs that
[Music]
oh never never doing that again
never doing that again how's it going
everybody its Warren and thanks to Tom
Holland and III we have a brand new
spider-man far from home TV spot where
he shows all of his new suits that he'll
have in the movie since the very first
teaser trailer came out for spider-man
far from home people have noticed that
spider-man is going to have many
different suits throughout this movie
and since Mysterio has thrown the word
multiverse out there some people think
that these actually could not be new
suits but actually could be spider-man
from different universes and although
that could be possible I think that has
been pretty much debunked for the most
part especially with this new TV spot
where Tom Holland and Marvel slash Sony
is introducing these new suits
now we've obviously seen these suits
before and all the TV spots and the
trailers but this new TV spot is all
about highlighting them his original
suit his new suit the newer suit and the
newest suit so his original suit is the
stark tech suit that he got from Tony
Stark and spider-man homecoming thanks
to the original trailer we know that
Peter will try to leave this suit at
home when he goes on vacation but we
also know that Aunt May packs it for him
and he does have this when he is on
vacation so this is the suit that he
will originally wear in spider-man far
from home but we have seen in other
trailers and TV spots that it does catch
on fire and gets destroyed this will
ultimately lead him to making a new suit
and we'll talk about that at the end but
then we have the new suit which is the
iron spider suit that he got in Avengers
infinity war and that we also saw him
wear an Avengers end game and it doesn't
seem like he'll be wearing this suit
very much in spider-man far from home in
fact we've only ever seen him wear the
iron spider suit and the spider-man far
from home clips that we have in the very
beginning scene with the Manfredi mob
once he leaves New York on vacation we
don't see him wearing the iron spider
suit at all but then we have the newer
suit which is the stealth suit or the
Spider Man you our suit this is a
minimalistic suit that Peter will get
from Nick Fury of shield now it's a
stealth suit so it's meant to be sneaky
it's meant for him to be able to get
around without being detected
it has been rumored that it does have
some camouflage capabilities although we
have not seen those in any of the TV
spots or trailers but he will most
likely be using this suit to spy on the
elementals and who is behind them I also
think that Nick Fury expects that
Mysterio is lines
somehow so he may give spider-man this
suit to go and spy on Mysterio and then
we have his newest suit with thanks to
the help of happy hogan he will make in
the secret lab of Tony Stark's jet and
we actually get new footage of him
making the suit here including him
choosing the spider-man logo and as we
see from this TV spot and other TV spots
his new suit is going to be red and
black with a little bit of white trim on
it this will probably be much like the
original stark suit that he got in
spider-man homecoming of course it will
probably have some advancements made to
it and of course that will most likely
have an AI in fact many people speculate
that Tony's voice could actually be used
for his new suits AI but that's
something that we'll have to wait and
see to find out when spider-man far from
home hits theaters in about two weeks so
that's it for all the new suits that Tom
Holland and Marvel / Sony are showing us
in this brand new spider-man far from
home TV spot for suits is a lot of
different suits for one movie but do you
think there could be more that they're
not showing us obviously they want us to
get excited which is why they're showing
us the suits but they don't want to
reveal the whole entire movie so let me
know in the comments down below what you
think about all the suits that he'll be
wearing and spider-man far from home and
if you think that he'll be getting more
suits and a reminder about my giveaway
when I hit 450,000 subscribers I'll be
giving away three items from the Marvel
Legends series collection to enter all
you have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
you're it